bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football l'équipe de versailles s'est
imposé ce dimanche 29 janvier contre
l'équipe 3 du paris saint germain une
victoire qui permet aux joueurs de la
cité royale de consolider leur place de
leader de la dh
nous y reviendrons dans un instant
handball un match insolite était
organisée ce jeudi soir les équipes de
france de gendarmerie masculine et
féminine ont affronté les seigneurs de
l'ès montignac balle
cette rencontre amicale permet tait de
préparer les deux équipes aux échéances
de cette deuxième partie de saison plus
d'informations à suivre
tir à l'arc les archers de guyancourt
ont organisé pour la troisième année
consécutive le concours régional jeunes
au gymnase maurice baquet plus de 190
participants ont fait le déplacement
pour cet événement coup de projecteur
dans ce magazine
zuma présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
au début de cette page résultats par du
football et le championnat de dh le
versailles fc 60,18 s'est imposé ce
week-end coin tout contre l'équipe 3 du
paris saint germain
les versaillais l'ont emporté 2 buts 1
sur leur pelouse du stade de mon bord
ont une victoire importante dans la
course à la montée les joueurs de la
cité royale compte désormais huit points
d'avancé sur le deuxième les gobelins
leur parcours est pour le moment proche
du sans faute en 13 matches joués les
versions réalisé 9 victoires 3 nuls et
ont concédé une seule défaite depuis le
début de la saison prochain match
dimanche prochain contre ivry toujours à
domicile du soccer on passe au football
américain les templiers d'elancourt en
chaîne dans le championnat de 2e
division
les élans courtois se sont imposés à
l'extérieur sur le terrain des corsaires
débris ce dimanche après midi comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images
menés pendant une bonne partie de la
rencontre les templiers ont haussé le
ton dans la deuxième partie du match
pour l'emporter 28 à 20 avec cette
victoire les templiers sont à égalité de
points avec les caïmans du mans prochain
match le 11 février à l'extérieur contre
les pygargues de troyes en rugby
après plusieurs matches annulés à cause
du froid la semaine dernière on a pu
enfin jouer sur les pelouse
le rugby-club de plaisir s'est imposé à
29 à 14 contre evreux à domicile ce
dimanche après midi
une victoire qui permet aux plaisirs wa
de rester en tête du championnat de
fédérale 3 devant ris orangis
les deux équipes sont à égalité avec 47
points au bout de onze journées à
disputer un mot de handball à présent
l'information principale de ce week-end
c'est évidemment le titre de champion du
monde de l'équipe de france les experts
ont remporté leur finale contre la
norvège sur le score de 33 à 26 8 6e
étoile acquise en grande partie grâce au
versailles et valentin porte
l'arrière droit des bleus inscrit 5 buts
sur 6 tentatives face aux scandinaves
à 26 ans le joueur qui évolue à
montpellier a déjà un palmarès digne des
plus grands une médaille d'or aux
championnats d'europe en 2014
deux médailles d'or aux championnats du
monde et une médaille d'argent aux jeux
olympiques de rio
les résultats de l'équipe de france de
handball ont un impact sur le nombre
d'inscrits dans l'hexagone il ya
aujourd'hui plus de 500 mille licenciés
contre 300 milles en 2001 le handball
est désormais le troisième sport
collectif national derrière le football
qui culmine à 2 millions de joueurs et
le basket qui compte six
cent quarante mille inscrits mais le
vent dépasse le rugby dans les yvelines
le président du comité des yvelines
patrick chabrot ce sens cette
effervescence sur le terrain et pensent
que leur balle peut encore grandir
le basket c'est fort possible puisqu'il
ya une forte augmentation des licenciés
cette année je prends comme repère les
yvelines
parallèlement à 8000 alors que la saison
passée à 7002 donc
donc c'est vrai qu'on dépasse et
l'effectif basque est oui le football
non parce que le nombre de licenciés est
tellement important par rapport au
niveau de la turballe que j'y crois pas
trop aux pays
mais sur le plan moyen moyens humains
financiers en jeu non on reste dans le
handball un match insolite était
organisée ce jeudi soir à
montigny-le-bretonneux les équipes de
france de gendarmerie masculine et
féminine ont affronté les seniors de
l'ès montignac balle cette rencontre
amicale permettait de préparer les deux
équipes aux échéances de cette deuxième
partie de saison des images d'alice
deschamps une rencontre de gala pour la
deuxième année consécutive les seniors
de l'ess montigny le bretonneux handball
recevait les équipes de france de
gendarmerie masculine et féminine ce
jeudi 26 janvier au gymnase pierre de
coubertin cette rencontre était
programmée dans le cadre d'un stage des
gendarmes en région parisienne on
cherchait un niveau de nationale pour
nos équipes puisque nos joueurs nous
viennent de toute la france
il songe en armes et il veut joue en
club en civil le week end
pour nous on est très fiers de fois
recevoir des équipes au sol d'une
corporation comme la gendarmerie pour
différentes choses sait déjà c'est le
rayonnement du club de montigny au
niveau national ça nous attire du monde
ça c'est aussi c'est assez glorieux pour
nous en venons à affronter
montigny-le-bretonneux l'équipe de
france de gendarmerie créé en 2015
voulait mettre en place une cohésion
d'équipé en vue des championnats de
france militaires programmée fin mars
c'est un groupe qui est très hétérogène
donc il ya des filles qui viennent de
d'un peu partout de niveaux complètement
différent donc c'est une force qu'il
faut utiliser parce qu on est obligé du
coup de jouer collectivement pour les
équipes seniors de montigny le
bretonneux cette rencontre amicale
devait permettre aux joueurs de se
maintenir en forme pendant la trêve
hivernale
bref très bon entraînement parce qu'on
joue des joueurs physiques des joueurs
qui ont un très bon niveau par rapport à
nous donc
on prend de l'expérience ça va nous
servir pour la suite chez les filles ce
match de préparation se termine sur le
score de 24 à 18 pour les gendarmes
c'était une bonne équipe bien préparée
assez physique plus physiques que nous
et
voilà donc c'est un bon entraînement
pour la suite du championnat
c'était toi pas on a mis de l'engagement
en défense on a tout pris du plaisir
voilà c'était super ça nous met en
confiance eux se soude encore plus le
groupe même si on était déjà bien sud à
la base et c'est top pour nous quoi du
côté des garçons les gendarmes l'ont
emporté 42 à 25 contre lézignan teint
les deux structures devraient se
retrouver l'année prochaine à l'occasion
d'un nouveau match amical
il y avait du tir à l'arc ce week-end à
guyancourt le club local organisé
pendant deux jours à concours régional
pour les jeunes au gymnase maurice
baquet 192 archers de la catégorie à
benjamin à catégorie à minimes ont
participé à cette compétition organisée
par la structure pour la troisième année
consécutive les images sont signés à
nicolas dans des il fallait du sang
froid et de la dextérité ce week-end
pour réaliser des performances au
concours régional jeunes de guyancourt
une véritable tradition pour le club
local qui a été sélectionné par la ligue
ile-de-france points 3e année
consécutive au rendez vous regroupez
encore cette année les meilleurs jeunes
archers d'île de france
en fait il ya un classement qui est fait
sur les trois meilleures performances de
toute la saison et à l'issue de ce
classement on extrait les x meilleurs
par catégorie
donc c'est les catégories les plus
représentées on va prendre plus de monde
et puis les catégories où il ya un peu
moins de participants
eh ben on va prendre juste quelques
quelques participants sur les deux jours
l'événement réunissant 92 jeunes archers
des catégories benjamins à minimes
pendant la compétition les sportifs ont
pu décocher deux séries de dix volées de
trois flèches pour montrer leur
précision 24 cibles ont été installés
dans la salle
c'est bien de s'affronter aux meilleurs
de l'île de france est donc aussi juste
pour permettre une compétition
l'expérience des duels et juste pour
m'amuser aussi en même temps pour voir
mon niveau par rapport aux autres
et puisque ya mon entraîneur aussi qui
m'a dit que c'était pas mal du coup pas
su agen il peut y avoir du bon niveau
mais oui oui c'est une bonne compétition
à faire les vainqueurs du jour ont pris
une sérieuse option en vue des
qualifications pour les championnats de
france jeunes 2017
la compétition sera organisée les 17 18
et 19 février à nîmes direction à
présent l'océan atlantique no 2 heavy
noix sont dans la dernière ligne droite
de ce huitième vendée globe alors que le
skipper de banque populaire armel le
cléac'h est arrivé le 19 janvier dernier
louis burton
originaire de rambouillet devrait lui
arriver aux sables d'olonne dans la nuit
de mercredi à jeudi il devrait se
classer septième de ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale de son côté le
verset éric bellion vient de passer
l'équateur aborde son imoca comme un
seul homme et occupe provisoirement la
9e place du classement le navigateur
enregistré cette séquence ce week-end
bienvenue sur comme un seul homme
voilà on a on est en train de toucher un
peu grand et surtout on est en train de
quitter l'amérique latine ça arrive tout
peut arriver
quinze jours de remonter d'amérique
latine ont été éprouvantes je vous le
dire parce que on s'est battus mille par
mille pour grimper est vraiment
mission difficile d'ailleurs merci pour
vos messages de soutien qu'ils m'ont
vraiment le plaisir et du bien un
portrait à présent dans ce set 8 sport
il a fait de sa passion un métier
olivier mazet 38 ans est aujourd'hui
considéré comme l'un des agents les de
basket les plus influents en france élan
courtois a lancé son entreprise maze
agency en 2006 et recense désormais 40
joueurs sous contrat dans son carnet on
retrouve des basketteurs évoluant en
proie ou les prochaines star française
de la nba nous avons réussi à
l'intercepter dans nos locaux entre un
déplacement aux états unis un autre
déplacement en chine
il était au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude j'ai voulu vraiment essayé de de
comprendre un petit peu le milieu de
savoir sur quel type de stratégie je
voulais je voulais me lancer
le recrutement la planification dans le
temps voilà de mes objectifs
donc ouais basculer complètement à de
2006 2006 complètement dans cette
profession là donc ça va faire 11 ans
l'ouverture de la société c'était en
avril 2006 donc voilà on va fêter sa
dixième année dans deux mois aujourd'hui
j'ai une clientèle de 40 joueurs qui
valent et de la pro a donc c'est la
première division française à la pro b
un petit peu nationale ubp certains
coachs de trois joueuses
donc j'ai des joueurs comme gars charlie
abuser et qui a été drafté par les
boston celtics cet été 16e choix de la
draft
c'est la deuxième plus grosse draft
française de l'histoire des garçons
comme charles kahudi international
français qui jouent en équipe de france
depuis 5 6 ans qui était aux jeux
olympiques cet été champion d'europe
avec eux les garçons comme jérémy joly
qui a gagné au concours de dunks all
star game récemment dans des garçons
comme franz mekyna qui est le jeune
prospect du moment qui est appelé à
rejoindre la nba est peut-être dans
quelques mois
voilà donc une clientèle qui est assez
varié quelques entraîneurs quelques
joueurs j'ai représenté pendant
longtemps emilie gomis
lorsqu'elle joue et qui était vice
championne olympique à londres
voilà voilà pour l'essentiel de la
clientèle donc une quarantaine de
joueurs et joueuses
voilà répartis sur l'europe les états
unis et la france
il ya deux façons de faire il ya on va
dire le démarchage classique de
présentation est entre guillemets de
deux présentations de projets voilà deux
d'essayer de leur vendre un projet qui
soit un projet global de représentation
de gestion de carrière et tous les à
côtés et moi aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
de pouvoir travailler on va dire à 90%
sur de la cooptation sur du relationnel
sur du réseau la plupart et voir la
quasi totalité de mes recrutements
seront à travers de certains de mes
joueurs de certains des entraîneurs que
je connais de différents acteurs du
milieu qui vont vous recommander ça
permet moi je pense d'avoir une barrière
de confiance qui est tout de suite
assez assez mises de côté si j'ai pu le
faire c'est que tout le monde peut le
faire je pense que voilà c'est la preuve
que tout est possible c'est vraiment
entre guillemets mis ma phrase créneau
mais mais voilà c'est quelque chose qui
est très élitiste
il ya énormément d'agents de joueurs en
france il ya un examen qui est mis en
place par la fédération française et le
ministère des sports
donc c'est quelque chose qui est au vert
je vais dire à tout le monde maintenant
voilà sûr je crois que la totalité des
120 agents qui sont licenciés je crois
qu'il y avait une vingtaine d'agents ce
qui travaillait régulièrement et on
devait être une dizaine je crois avoir
on va dire plus de 15 20 joueurs
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
assez élitiste qui est très
concurrentiel qui est très très
concurrentiel mais voilà je pense qu'à
force de travail et passion parce que je
pense que le dénominateur commun de tous
ces gens là c'est la passion je pense
que c'est un métier qui est très
chronophage qui assez usant physiquement
faut avoir une véritable passion pour
l'univers du sport du basket en
particulier pour pouvoir durer dans ce
milieu là oui c'est la fin de ce statut
de sport merci d'avoir suivi en sorte au
lundi prochain pour un nouveau magazine
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]